will be basically I one thing that we
didn't say earlier that I think kind of
ties in here is that what's interesting
about this film I think particular is
that we're talking about tiny houses but
but really we're talking about much
bigger issues that we're using sort of
the vehicle of type people who the tiny
houses to talk about these things I
worry it's really the impact reaches all
the way through you know consumerism and
it you know downsizing there's the size
of homes there's all these these bigger
implications and it's like it's actually
really quite fascinating and so I think
when we're talking about tiny homes it's
really just a manifestation of people
wrestling with much larger issues yeah
and that's what's great about the kind
of the whole idea at home you know and
and it's this thing that everyone knows
what it is but it's really hard to
explain like what it is that you feel
when you feel home you know and I think
that's kind of a question of people just
you know trying to it's kind of a
question that everyone's kind of asking
all the time and all these different
actions that we're doing we're kind of
you know looking for that sense of one
other it's like a sense of comfort or a
sense of belonging or a sense of like
this is my place I feel really good here
you know and that that yeah that allows
us access to talk about a lot of other
things yeah you know cuz they you know
trying to make a film about home or film
about consumerism I mean it's just so
hard but when you when you can like
focus in on one little manifestation of
that suddenly you can like really
tangibly grass grapple with these issues
you know so are those some of the things
that embody home for you just yeah I
mean I think personally um yeah I think
you know I have been thinking a lot
about about home throughout this project
and I think you know the things that
I've learned is that it has a lot to do
with people you know it has a lot to do
with for me kind of like the aesthetics
of you know location
landscape and you know the few little
things that are around that kind of
inspired me and helped me to feel like
you know kind of like my best you know
kind of person that I can be yeah yeah
definitely I think you know people place
in security are three big ones you know
the community or the family that you're
asserting yourself with the place that
had situated that the town the city the
landscape you know and then just having
a place to feel secure emotionally
physically from you know that's yours
that you kind of have control over in
space and those seem to be the essential
essential elements along with those
physical you know taking every physical
needs like cooking bathroom you know
places sleep think something
you